Caption: all right so I'll start so if you
Caption: haven't got paper and you'd like to draw
Caption: there's some paper pens and pencils at
Caption: the front most people just carry a
Caption: laptop or a phone or a tablet nowadays
Caption: if you want to draw on your tablet
Caption: please draw on your tablet as well
Caption: so I'm running this presentation as a
Caption: whiteboard from a tablet okay so it's
Caption: not a PowerPoint
Caption: and sometimes I stuff up because I'm
Caption: using a pencil and it doesn't work so
Caption: well when I'm I'm going so bear with me
Caption: if I if I go a little bit off track so
Caption: my name is Phil Wilde and I'm a
Caption: Solutions engineer with a company called
Caption: confluent and if you don't know who
Caption: Confluence is the founders of confluent
Caption: created Apache Kafka but I'm not going
Caption: to talk about that today I'm going to
Caption: talk about drawing
Caption: so
Caption: the agenda
Caption: doodling and drawing expressing ideas
Caption: and Concepts through Visual
Caption: communication and this is kind of my
Caption: journey because I didn't draw a few
Caption: years ago in fact if you look at my
Caption: drawings a year ago completely different
Caption: to to how I draw now and how I sort of
Caption: run a presentation or a whiteboard and I
Caption: try not to use PowerPoint anymore I try
Caption: to always use a whiteboard when I'm
Caption: presenting something
Caption: so first
Caption: I'll say thank you to our sponsors today
Caption: especially the coffee sponsors
Caption: Okay so
Caption: a question
Caption: who in a room
Caption: feels that they're comfortable drawing
Caption: hands up
Caption: cool some of us all right people coming
Caption: in if you want to grab some paper have
Caption: you forgotten yet all right good thank
Caption: you
Caption: um
Caption: all right I've always been very
Caption: comfortable in front of a whiteboard but
Caption: my drawing has been pretty crap up until
Caption: about a year ago
Caption: so
Caption: um in here you'll see when I'm moving my
Caption: fingers so you'll see little little dots
Caption: okay
Caption: all right so I'm gonna
Caption: I'm gonna Draw Something
Caption: on a board on a paper on a flip chart
Caption: okay
Caption: now I don't think
Caption: my handwriting is very good but
Caption: bear with me
Caption: Okay so
Caption: something simple
Caption: not very good but what does that look
Caption: like
Caption: fire yep
Caption: I can shade with other colors but
Caption: shading kind of helps sometimes
Caption: right so I'm going to call it number one
Caption: now that didn't work very well at all
Caption: right can I get that back
Caption: uh yeah there it is
Caption: okay
Caption: so we might we might use fire you know
Caption: when we're working
Caption: um something that's hot or maybe
Caption: something that's dangerous as well right
Caption: or something that might need attention
Caption: foreign
Caption: quite simple a little bit of shading
Caption: [Music]
Caption: a factory industry a location
Caption: okay
Caption: this one's quite relevant to us here in
Caption: Western Australia isn't it
Caption: right
Caption: a shark Danger
Caption: so these symbols are really quick to
Caption: draw so if you're actually running a
Caption: whiteboard session you can you can add
Caption: them to Pages as as you need them right
Caption: people walking in there's paper pencils
Caption: at the front if you want to copy and
Caption: please if you want copy this if if you
Caption: want to copy as I go
Caption: foreign
Caption: setting a goal right being able to draw
Caption: something on you know on a whiteboard to
Caption: say this is our goal and just represent
Caption: it visually
Caption: a flip chart would have worked better
Caption: but uh
Caption: this goes all right
Caption: so perhaps
Caption: foreign
Caption: we're on a journey
Caption: right very simple helicopter
Caption: number five
Caption: and the last one I'm going to draw
Caption: all right skull
Caption: and crossbones
Caption: right again for danger very easy to do
Caption: didn't take long if they're quite simple
Caption: basic shapes you put them together
Caption: but you have to remember them if you're
Caption: going to draw them
Caption: so that's how I do it on a flip chart
Caption: this is how I would present it
Caption: on a light board right
Caption: that I would have to do this ahead of
Caption: time I can't draw quickly
Caption: however I do pre-draw these and put them
Caption: in a library so that I can just pop them
Caption: on when I'm when I'm working with a
Caption: light board
Caption: okay
Caption: so I don't know if this is true or not
Caption: but when I Googled
Caption: right
Caption: the fear of whiteboarding
Caption: I can't draw you know last time I drew
Caption: was with a crayon I went on five
Caption: um a lot of people are like this you
Caption: walk into a room and say can you draw
Caption: this and it's like no I can't draw you
Caption: know I can draw sticks stick figures
Caption: that's about it
Caption: so this has taken just from Wikipedia
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: the use of visual elements to convey
Caption: ideas and information okay using
Caption: fonts science topography drawing
Caption: so why why do we want to do this okay
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: one things it it relays message is much
Caption: faster if you can put some imagery in
Caption: there right I'm sure you've all heard
Caption: the the saying a picture a picture is
Caption: worth a thousand words
Caption: it can remove ambiguity
Caption: um you know a comma in a wrong spot
Caption: changes things with the English language
Caption: if you draw it with a picture a diagram
Caption: or something like that it's it's right
Caption: in front of you and I worked as an
Caption: architect and I still do sort of
Caption: architecture stuff for a long time go in
Caption: a room you put the picture up everyone's
Caption: got it in front of them and you're
Caption: talking to it and changing it okay as
Caption: opposed to trying to read through and
Caption: understand it you bring it in much much
Caption: faster
Caption: okay
Caption: okay so I'm going to talk a little bit
Caption: about my journey all right and I'll do
Caption: it with with pictures
Caption: so
Caption: I don't know when you're in school and
Caption: you're asked to draw a landscape this is
Caption: kind of what you drew you know the
Caption: Horizon some mountains the sun gave it
Caption: some color
Caption: so I'm going to start there
Caption: all right and this is my journey
Caption: so about 10 years ago
Caption: um I was using physical whiteboards
Caption: and these are the sort of things I was
Caption: you know putting up on the screen
Caption: pretty bland but I guess they got the um
Caption: the message across as to what we're
Caption: trying to do
Caption: okay and about 2012 I I wanted to start
Caption: taking digital notes and and using a
Caption: tablet so I bought a stylus optimized
Caption: tablet
Caption: 2012 the apple pencil still didn't exist
Caption: you were told to use a finger
Caption: and um so I bought an Android tablet and
Caption: um I it never really worked well
Caption: um but I I persisted I went through
Caption: about four different Android tablets
Caption: with styluses
Caption: um but my
Caption: my drawing on a tablet
Caption: looked worse than it did on a whiteboard
Caption: okay but I was using it
Caption: then
Caption: this happened
Caption: okay and everyone stopped going into an
Caption: office and I I no longer had access to a
Caption: whiteboard
Caption: um but we had Zoom
Caption: and all of a sudden a tablet with a pen
Caption: became really really handy I could you
Caption: know join the zoom meeting with my
Caption: tablet and I could draw kind of like on
Caption: a whiteboard but I was still pretty crap
Caption: at drawing okay still really crappy
Caption: drawing but at least I was able to do
Caption: something
Caption: and then early last year I changed jobs
Caption: and I started working for with confluent
Caption: and as a as an organization for their
Caption: Solutions Engineers of which I'm a
Caption: Solutions engineer
Caption: um they had enabled
Caption: um their Workforce with an iPad with an
Caption: app called Concepts that I hadn't used
Caption: before
Caption: and some other tools and I'll go through
Caption: the tools
Caption: and it was a little bit eye opening I
Caption: thought wow this is really cool this
Caption: this actually works so if I show you
Caption: um
Caption: I guess what my whiteboards look like
Caption: within about a month of starting working
Caption: with those tools
Caption: at uh at Confluence so definitely
Caption: improved right I'm starting to to draw
Caption: things out now one of the nice things
Caption: about Concepts and I I'm going to say if
Caption: you've got a an iPad even if you've got
Caption: Android Concepts works on the Android
Caption: but the documents aren't compatible
Caption: between them and there's it's sort of a
Caption: couple of versions behind on Android
Caption: it's still okay all right but
Caption: um the infinite canvas so I can scroll
Caption: left right out in it it's just good to
Caption: be able to you know zoom into detail
Caption: like I'm doing here
Caption: okay and in about two months after I
Caption: joined we had someone you come into
Caption: leadership and she suggested because we
Caption: were all using this that we should maybe
Caption: do some training in it and um I attended
Caption: a two-day workshop
Caption: um on visual facilitation
Caption: by a company in Australia called The
Caption: Humble PM now becablo is a German
Caption: company they
Caption: um they basically sell material around
Caption: visual facilitation and
Caption: um there's a guy called Mark cundeleby
Caption: that runs these courses so they're quite
Caption: expensive it's about fifteen hundred
Caption: dollars if you can get your company to
Caption: to sponsor you know this it'd be really
Caption: cool
Caption: and
Caption: um
Caption: I'm going to show you these drawings
Caption: here that I started this this morning
Caption: that's using the becablo sort of
Caption: technique
Caption: all right and this this kind of really
Caption: took off for me right so my my drawing
Caption: just changed and it it
Caption: changed on a sort of a rapid
Caption: um progression
Caption: so I will go into the tools
Caption: so with digital
Caption: I have an iPad
Caption: and drawing with a pencil on an iPad if
Caption: you've got one it's it's not very good
Caption: it sort of slips and slides everywhere
Caption: um Samsung with their Stylus is much
Caption: much better I much prefer to note take
Caption: on a Samsung Style on a Samsung tablet
Caption: and and I use that in meetings so I
Caption: typically carry a Macbook my iPad and a
Caption: Samsung tablet so lots of things to keep
Caption: charged it gets better if you put a
Caption: screen protector on the glass and you
Caption: can get this one off of Amazon it's
Caption: called uh it's from Belmond it's about
Caption: 25 for two screen protectors
Caption: and it gives it a bit of a matte finish
Caption: so it feels more like writing on paper
Caption: they've tried to emulate their paper
Caption: with the pencil so I would recommend it
Caption: and of course the concepts app this is a
Caption: really good app
Caption: and if you have problems their support's
Caption: really good it's only a small team out
Caption: of California that write this
Caption: and then lastly
Caption: you don't need this and I could show you
Caption: how this works except my macbook's at
Caption: the back of the room so I can't uh it
Caption: basically is a airplay receiver running
Caption: on your Macbook so that I can present
Caption: from my iPad up here or wherever it is
Caption: onto a screen somewhere with a HDMI
Caption: cable
Caption: okay so that's digital
Caption: now
Caption: with paper
Caption: if you do the vocabulary course and you
Caption: don't have to do it but if you do it you
Caption: get one of these sort of packs and you
Caption: get these refillable pens from Newland
Caption: and they have like hundreds of colors
Caption: they have them for paper they have them
Caption: for whiteboards
Caption: very large tips for doing shading and
Caption: things so they're really good if you
Caption: sort of you know if your work is in a
Caption: room and you are you know doing sort of
Caption: agile facilitation and you want to draw
Caption: out a journey or something like that and
Caption: you're doing it on paper these are
Caption: really good much better than what you
Caption: can get from an officeworks
Caption: okay
Caption: now they're expensive and you can buy
Caption: them online also with actually I'll show
Caption: that later I'll leave that for now
Caption: and again I've also I've already
Caption: mentioned this but uh with whiteboards
Caption: again the Newland markers and I'm going
Caption: to suggest that if you're buying markers
Caption: buy the ones that have
Caption: the sort of rectangular tips
Caption: you have chisel tip is that what it's
Caption: called cool there you go learn something
Caption: so you can use both edges right so my
Caption: little people here they're just sort of
Caption: emulated it on my tablet is the wide one
Caption: to draw the bodies and a narrow one to
Caption: draw the heads and arms
Caption: so uh
Caption: all right
Caption: so now this is a follow along
Caption: how to draw
Caption: okay
Caption: so please uh copy me if you want to
Caption: right
Caption: lines these are simple
Caption: easy
Caption: getting a bit harder
Caption: so these Newland Pens have places for
Caption: your your finger so you're always
Caption: holding it the right way so that tip
Caption: touches the paper the way it's supposed
Caption: to
Caption: and I'm never good at making circles
Caption: circles but that's that one that one
Caption: turned out pretty good
Caption: all right
Caption: squiggly shapes
Caption: right
Caption: and the last ones
Caption: are the other shapes
Caption: all right
Caption: my shark fin
Caption: and the letter u
Caption: so
Caption: if you can do all those shapes you can
Caption: draw all of the vicablo
Caption: symbols
Caption: so
Caption: like that
Caption: all right very quick to draw something
Caption: and of course
Caption: shading helps
Caption: so here's some other shapes
Caption: and again you'll see them all in
Caption: the vocabulary shapes
Caption: and again
Caption: coloring shading
Caption: really changes the way they look
Caption: so let's draw some more
Caption: try these
Caption: okay and for these
Caption: all right
Caption: our shark fin
Caption: can you see I've got some no you can't
Caption: see it at all I've got some cheats on
Caption: there it's turned out it's very good
Caption: right so
Caption: a meeting between two people
Caption: now Matsu
Caption: let me draw Matsu right but I'm going to
Caption: do in a different order I'm going to do
Caption: the o
Caption: I'm going to do the m
Caption: I'm going to do a u
Caption: and a z
Caption: I'll do them on the screen
Caption: just check my Pen's working yeah
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right shading
Caption: now containers
Caption: when drawing containers and actually I
Caption: won't do it on the white on the on the
Caption: uh
Caption: right draw the words
Caption: then draw the Box around it if you draw
Caption: the Box first your words won't fit
Caption: all right
Caption: so you know just being able to all right
Caption: I'm drawing a an architectural diagram
Caption: and I've got a secure area dropping a
Caption: dropping a lock in a corner that's
Caption: either locked or unlocked you can draw
Caption: that in 10 seconds just to to make it
Caption: you know much easier than writing a
Caption: secure zone right or unsecure Zone
Caption: so
Caption: um I got these two books when I did the
Caption: training
Caption: and
Caption: um they they basically talk through lots
Caption: of different techniques and shapes and
Caption: everything I've just taken two photos
Caption: just so you can see some of the um the
Caption: symbols I've drawn some already today
Caption: you would have seen
Caption: all right
Caption: so I'm going to draw people now
Caption: because this really comes down to how
Caption: much time you want to spend so it could
Caption: be as simple as an upside down you and a
Caption: line and it looks like a person right a
Caption: little bit of shading helps it even if
Caption: you're doing that on the you know on the
Caption: Run
Caption: you don't need to put arms but when we
Caption: draw stick figures you know our arms
Caption: don't come out of our tummies they come
Caption: out from under our necks so you draw
Caption: your arms at the top
Caption: you know you can start to do
Caption: actions like falling pointing
Caption: the difference and in fact if if you're
Caption: looking at this guy I copied
Caption: the guy that's sort of like two to the
Caption: left and added the legs thickened his
Caption: arms and added the shading
Caption: and then sort of the stick figure guy I
Caption: like these from there I like how they
Caption: look
Caption: so again the Whiteboard people these are
Caption: very quick to draw using the the pen
Caption: with the chiseled tip
Caption: and once you get the hang of drawing
Caption: people then you can you know start to
Caption: have them do things so a team being led
Caption: on a journey in a boat
Caption: very quick easy to to draw
Caption: is this kind of cool
Caption: emotions
Caption: so
Caption: happy you don't need to put eyes for
Caption: happy smiley faces is really all you
Caption: need
Caption: shock pondering or thought scared
Caption: if you don't want to draw faces you can
Caption: use symbolism as well right very easy to
Caption: uh to just give an idea you can you can
Caption: dress them up in hats here
Caption: okay now
Caption: if you have to
Caption: I'm going to say
Caption: don't draw
Caption: don't draw the stick man
Caption: it's just as easy to draw two long legs
Caption: and a pair of arms and it just comes
Caption: across as a lot better right
Caption: so I'll save I'll give this to you as a
Caption: as a a JPEG afterwards as well
Caption: so writing is the next thing
Caption: and this is a thing I hate
Caption: so this is my writing
Caption: all right a shocking
Caption: I can barely read it
Caption: and if I have to do something fast and
Caption: if I'm nervous like in a room of people
Caption: it gets even worse
Caption: so this is the becablo style of writing
Caption: okay and the one thing is it's really
Caption: compact right much much more compact
Caption: than my handwriting so you can fit it
Caption: into flip charts really easily you can
Caption: get a lot more letters in so it's good
Caption: and the thing that makes it readable is
Caption: the really tall skinny
Caption: lowercase characters
Caption: now Concepts sucks at this
Caption: this is the only font you have in
Caption: Concepts it's helvetica or aerial and
Caption: it's really long and you don't get a
Caption: choice it's one they say fonts are
Caption: coming later next year but
Caption: um so that means I have to handwrite
Caption: everything
Caption: so how do I do that when my writing
Caption: sucks
Caption: well
Caption: I've made my own font of all the letters
Caption: I use
Caption: and then I copy paste
Caption: and manually
Caption: Kern
Caption: and this this kind of sucks right
Caption: it kind of looks neat when you're
Caption: watching it and my teammates when they
Caption: see me doing this they kind of you know
Caption: that sort of satisfying videos that you
Caption: see where people are lining up the
Caption: letters and well other things so that's
Caption: how I do this it takes a long time
Caption: um so I have a shortcut
Caption: and I have a um I use a lucidchart as
Caption: well so I've hand drawn a font that
Caption: kinda matches with looser chart so I
Caption: will sometimes use this instead of the
Caption: vocabulary font and if I go to here
Caption: um
Caption: I didn't write that I went into
Caption: lucidchart I typed it in I saved it as a
Caption: transparent jpeg I airdropped it onto
Caption: the iPad I imported it in and and
Caption: dropped it into my diagram and that's
Caption: much faster than writing paragraphs so
Caption: if I have to write paragraphs and put it
Caption: in mostly I don't because mostly I'm
Caption: just drawing pictures but if I have to
Caption: that's the way I go
Caption: so I'm really looking forward to our
Caption: Concepts supporting more fonts
Caption: so actually going back to this
Caption: um and the
Caption: um it improves
Caption: memory right if I were to bring up
Caption: the original flip chart
Caption: where was a helicopter
Caption: hands up
Caption: was it there number two
Caption: no it pans out when I go to the right
Caption: one
Caption: it was five yeah
Caption: all right
Caption: so had I written down the helicopters as
Caption: a list you probably wouldn't remember it
Caption: right
Caption: faces I'm almost done
Caption: so
Caption: everyone want to draw this
Caption: step one draw the nose
Caption: then a smile
Caption: foreign
Caption: 66 for eyes
Caption: some spiky hair
Caption: chin
Caption: a neck
Caption: collar
Caption: and shoulders
Caption: let's start that again
Caption: a nose
Caption: a mustache
Caption: the same ear
Caption: a pair of glasses
Caption: a chin
Caption: make the neck
Caption: bolt head
Caption: right
Caption: and that's done
Caption: so
Caption: kind of on time
Caption: who thinks they can do that
Caption: a few more all right that's good
Caption: so my journey
Caption: where are we
Caption: if I go back to now
Caption: um
Caption: these are some diagrams that I've
Caption: started so
Caption: before the cablo this is just a picture
Caption: from a whiteboard that are driven right
Caption: are drawn so scribbling coloring in that
Caption: sort of thing
Caption: um so I tend to call this a light board
Caption: where you're you're drawing with light
Caption: on a black background
Caption: after vocablo
Caption: I switched to a whiteboard so this was
Caption: my first attempt
Caption: and this was in a week of of using the
Caption: Tableau I had redrawn
Caption: um using the kevlow technique of shading
Caption: and coloring and the shapes Etc
Caption: and then
Caption: this is kind of where I am now where I'm
Caption: I'm painstakingly neat because I use
Caption: these over and over and over again it's
Caption: like a it's like a book you know reading
Caption: a story to a classroom where I'm
Caption: flipping pages so
Caption: um yeah I've put time into into
Caption: something that I'm going to use more
Caption: than half a dozen times or in this case
Caption: a presentation I do once but uh anyway
Caption: so this is the same version as a light
Caption: board and Visually I like the the
Caption: brightness of the imagery on black but
Caption: it's a it's a personal choice
Caption: now two weeks ago I gave a I gave a talk
Caption: on data mesh at a
Caption: um
Caption: at an event in Perth and I'm not without
Caption: stepping through it like I stepped
Caption: through this this was
Caption: this was the presentation it's the first
Caption: time I sort of gave a presentation with
Caption: a tablet and a pen in front of a big
Caption: room but I tend to have slides in
Caption: meetings where I do you know agenda
Caption: go through problems where I might
Caption: document it
Caption: um
Caption: uh so on and then you know the the
Caption: imagery and I'm just panning through
Caption: this I will if there are things that are
Caption: I need to bring in I'll bring him in as
Caption: a screenshot and just sort of frame them
Caption: in my
Caption: um in my light boards you can see here
Caption: my people
Caption: okay
Caption: um drawing interesting things like uh
Caption: for example you know finding a balance
Caption: between central and decentralized
Caption: governance putting on a seesaw just
Caption: coming up with ideas about how you want
Caption: to portray something that you're you're
Caption: talking about so this is this was a
Caption: 20-minute talk and that was everything
Caption: that I had talked about and I'm going to
Caption: switch to a different
Caption: document now so this is going to go away
Caption: and I'm going to go in here
Caption: foreign
Caption: storytelling
Caption: sort of light board
Caption: so again I have my meeting hygiene
Caption: slides okay which I go through
Caption: uh history of confluent and Apache Kafka
Caption: and then I have my storytelling so all
Caption: this
Caption: I hand draw right and I can bring them
Caption: up and shut them down depending on you
Caption: know the story I want to take there's
Caption: about six stories in this light board
Caption: everything is turned on
Caption: and that's it so that's my presentation
Caption: questions how much time do we have
Caption: because I think I'm probably are we at
Caption: time
Caption: okay
Caption: um how you get the ideas to generate
Caption: these stories
Caption: um
Caption: some of them are from so it might be a
Caption: presentation
Caption: or it might be a YouTube video that has
Caption: a concept around let's just say it's you
Caption: know in my role I might need to talk
Caption: about data warehouse modernization so
Caption: I'll take ideas and I will typically
Caption: start with a flow so I will scribble out
Caption: in a layer within Concepts just wording
Caption: or pictures as to what as to how I
Caption: wanted to to make the story
Caption: and then I start from the first part to
Caption: the last part drawing out the bits and
Caption: pieces that I want to talk about and
Caption: then just sort of Crossing them off as I
Caption: go all right and then once so what I
Caption: haven't done is I within Concepts and
Caption: the way I've worked this is I have all
Caption: the different steps in my story in
Caption: different layers so what I was doing
Caption: with the pen and in fact what I can show
Caption: you is in Concepts I can it has a
Caption: presentation mode which is good what I'm
Caption: going to go here is just to mirror
Caption: everything
Caption: and now you can see the toolbar so over
Caption: on the right in this one there are
Caption: layers and I can turn these on and off
Caption: as I go so building out that story once
Caption: I do one new layer draw the new one new
Caption: layer draw the new one and also with the
Caption: um with the like if I'm drawing out
Caption: icons so here where I've got shading
Caption: that's potentially three layers so the
Caption: the line around the outside the coloring
Caption: on the inside and then if I want to put
Caption: a shadow in there there's a layer
Caption: underneath which I then combined to that
Caption: object
Caption: uh I think you might have answered this
Caption: but are these like reusable company yes
Caption: yes so what I do is um over you can see
Caption: my screen now on the left I have things
Caption: that I've imported into a toolbar so I
Caption: can uh for example
Caption: if I do that right drop them in and use
Caption: them so the things I use more I drop in
Caption: so it makes it much easier to do and and
Caption: then hence it becomes a lot faster than
Caption: drawing it on a on a piece of paper
Caption: now the funny thing is so in Concepts uh
Caption: a double tap is undo and a triple tap is
Caption: redo and occasionally now if I'm doing
Caption: this and i stuff it up I'll do that
Caption: and it's like you know it it just
Caption: becomes natural once you start using
Caption: this all the time and you go into other
Caption: apps and I double tap I know I've got to
Caption: hit the undo button but
Caption: hello
Caption: are you able to pre-configure the views
Caption: for the storytelling steps are you
Caption: constantly now that no I'm constantly
Caption: paging right okay
Caption: um I have thought about drawing them up
Caption: and then potentially using something
Caption: like Prezi but
Caption: when you're in a meeting it sometimes
Caption: you'll get taken off track and doing
Caption: that in a Prezi is is a bit hard so you
Caption: just have to I mean I'm kind of used to
Caption: it and it makes it interactive and I
Caption: always get lots of feedback at the end
Caption: of a meeting how did you do that right
Caption: foreign
Caption: do you have like any tips for showing
Caption: how to do uh like
Caption: cleaning up like relations between
Caption: things like this talks this is grouped
Caption: of this
Caption: um it kind of like how you do it on
Caption: paper so
Caption: um if I were to to just draw something
Caption: you know
Caption: uh actually that's Let Me So within here
Caption: you can see you can change
Caption: how things work so
Caption: you know doing it very quickly but you
Caption: can see in this diagram how I've got
Caption: like lots of arrows and things that
Caption: that's I
Caption: I have a um boxes inside other boxes
Caption: um you know connectors that you hand
Caption: draw
Caption: is there any sort of thing you'd like to
Caption: sort of
Caption: go beyond that or
Caption: no it's um so one of the things I do is
Caption: I'll draw something and I think well
Caption: that doesn't fit so then what I need to
Caption: do is you know I'll be selecting large
Caption: areas
Caption: and then I have to wait for that because
Caption: that's quite complex and then I'll move
Caption: them around
Caption: right so quite often when I'm doing the
Caption: drawings
Caption: um it doesn't work the way I want it and
Caption: then I have to start reorganizing the
Caption: puzzle
Caption: have you heard of the tool Miro yes okay
Caption: yep so Miro is very good for those
Caption: online where you've got lots of people
Caption: working at the same time but most of
Caption: those people are working with a mouse
Caption: right you're you're putting a Post-It
Caption: note on a piece of paper and you're
Caption: drawing drawing with a mouse is so hard
Caption: yeah yeah
Caption: but miro's cool it is right for
Caption: so how do you share your slides after
Caption: presentations ah so after I've
Caption: um I've done something and and typically
Caption: what I'll do is I'll have a layer in
Caption: here which is where I put my notes so
Caption: actions and everything else
Caption: um uh it's export
Caption: um uh choose the format so jpeg whether
Caption: it says selection or the entire drawing
Caption: whether I want um a black or or white
Caption: background the resolution and then I'll
Caption: airdrop it to my Mac and send it out as
Caption: a PDF
Caption: so what I will do
Caption: if if you want this
Caption: you can reach out to me on LinkedIn or I
Caption: don't know how is there a way of putting
Caption: giving the presentations out afterwards
Caption: yeah so I'll I'll export this as a JPEG
Caption: at the end
Caption: good um thanks everyone so much please
Caption: give another round of applause for the
Caption: amazing Fair
Caption: thank you